Each of these stages happens to map very nicely to the Dat C data science track.
What the first stage is concerned with,
you will encounter in the data wrangling class with MongoDB.
The second stage,
is often the domain of what people consider exploratory data analysis.
Which you'll encounter in the data analysis with our class, but other classes
such as modeling, statistics, and machine learning also apply to this stage.
And the last two stages are what we will encounter in this data
visualization class.
Lessons one and two will focus on data visualization theory where you'll
learn how best to visually represent your data.
And how to sketch or prototype a visualization to arrive at a final design.
And finally, in lessons three and
lesson four we will learn how to construct narratives around your data and
leverage interaction to create engaging experiences for our audience and reader.
And while this diagram might be biased towards the visualization process,
since Ben Fry got his PhD from the Aesthetics & Computation Group at
MIT's Media Lab, I don't mind since that's what this class will focus on.